Speaker 1: You know, we've had a number of
examples over the last couple of weeks to
a couple of months of different things being
equated to being like the Holocaust or like
World War Two or like historical attacks on
Jews and incorrectly so.
And now the sort of natural and and predictable
next step in this is taking place, which is
that we're starting to see segments on right
wing media saying that teaching critical race
theory or certainly critical race theory being
part of the national understanding of how
things work is like the Holocaust.
We're going to have a clip of this with right
wing radio host Michael Savage.
Now, I do feel I know that some people get
angry when I do the disclaimers.
I feel that it's necessary.
Here I am a critic of critical race theory.
I've critiqued critical race theory along
the lines that I've critiqued other theories
that come out of the post-modernist and post-structuralist
ideology.
I've critiqued critical race theory as reductive.
But critical race theory is not like the Holocaust.
It's that that's a wild and crazy thing to
say.
The Daily Beast summarizes.
Newsmax goes.
Their critical race theory is the road to
death camps for white people.
Right wing radio talker Michael Savage declared
the obscure academic theory akin to the Holocaust,
prompting a supportive response from a Newsmax
TV host.
Far right radio host Michael Savage took conservative's
latest moral panic to a bonkers new level
during a Monday night Newsmax appearance,
warning that the teaching of so-called critical
race theory in schools is akin to exactly
what was done to the Jews in Germany.
Now, that is not true.
We're going to look at the video clip.
Michael Savage is a guy we've covered on the
program for a long time.
He is desperate to maintain some level of
relevance and comparing things to the Holocaust,
especially when you yourself are Jewish.
And remember that that's something that the
right is playing up.
Michael Savage is Jewish.
That makes it get more attention.
It doesn't make it any more accurate.
Let's take a listen to this.
And by the way, the people who decry the identity
politics say, I don't know, should we listen
to Savage because he is Jewish after all,
maybe he can tell us what things are like
the Holocaust.
Here we go
Speaker 4: by blood boiling.
Listening to Chuck Todd, I wanted to reach
through the screen and smack him in the face.
Speaker 1: This is, by the way, if you're
not familiar with Michael Savage, this is
how he normally talks.
And it's just a way that it's part of his
shtick essentially to talk in this.
He's just constantly outraged at everything.
Speaker 4: Everybody does he have children.
Can you imagine having a little child who
goes to school and is told that he's no good,
is racist, no good, he's evil.
His parents are evil, his nation is evil.
These are the same as Sobeys will lecture
us for 20 years about don't be a bully, tolerate
everything.
And now they're beating up white children
in school rooms.
And I'm not going to mince words.
You can cut me off if you have to.
I know you probably agree with me.
I can't take this anymore.
And there's only one solution to it.
Sue the goddamn schools if they do it to your
child for child abuse.
Speaker 1: Now, when he says if they do it
to your child for child abuse, I have said
before, I do think that as a starting point,
teaching children that they are in some way
part of a bad group because of the color of
their skin.
I am against that.
And that's bad.
For the most part, critical race theory is
taught to college students and only in certain
relevant classes that college students have
chosen to take.
What Michael Savage is referring to, which
exists very anecdotally and I would be against
it, but it is not really.
The issue is certain exercises that have been
done in elementary or junior high schools,
which start to sort of frame the question
of race and goodness and badness in a way
that I don't think is useful or productive
in any way to bettering race relations.
But remember that this is part of the ruse.
The vast majority of what would fall under
the guise of critical race theory is being
taught to college students and it is being
taught as a theory.
It is not being taught as you were bad for
this reason or that reason that relates to
your skin color.
So the whole framing here is wrong.
But let's get to the really crazy part.
Speaker 4: You will win because that's the
only way to stop this.
These children are being you.
Elevated and hurt and damaged for life by
a psychotic woman who came up with this lie
called critical race theory, which is nothing
but racism towards white people, no other
race is targeted.
I could go on and I could go on and on.
I studied history.
I know where this starts.
I know where it ends.
It started in the same kind of thing, started
in Germany.
The Jews were no good.
The Jews did this.
The Jews did that.
The next thing you knew, they were being excluded
from swimming pools.
They didn't put them in concentration camps
overnight.
I study this intimately.
Speaker 1: Now, what's really interesting
about the analogy to the Holocaust is completely
wrong.
But Michael Savage says something really interesting
there, which is he says it didn't happen overnight.
That phrase very accurately describes the
creeping authoritarianism and nuttery that
we saw under Donald Trump.
If on the day after Trump was elected in twenty
sixteen, I had told you by the end of this,
Trump will be trying to steal an election
he clearly lost, trying to use the Department
of Justice and all of these different aspects
of government to do his bidding, demanding
that the Supreme Court do X, Y and Z, all
of the different mishandling a pandemic during
which he will suggest that infected Americans
be sent to Guantanamo Bay.
Nobody would have believed it if I had said
that on November 8th of 2016 or whatever the
date was.
But it slowly creeps in to the point where
by the time those things were happening, the
response was nowhere near what it should have
been.
It doesn't apply here the critical race theory,
but it would have applied if Michael Savage
had talked about this in relation to Trump's
creeping authoritarianism.
Just a few more seconds here.
Speaker 4: I'm Jewish.
I know how this starts attacks.
Speaker 1: That's identity politics.
But that's the identity politics they decry
because he's Jewish, he must be right about
what things are like.
Speaker 4: The Holocaust on white people is
exactly what was done to the Jews in Germany
in the 30s.
Don't fall for this garbage.
This is the road to the death camps.
Stand up to these bastards and sue them.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there is Michael Savage and it is yet another
analogy to the Holocaust that makes absolutely
no sense.
And the sad thing about this is there there
are real serious critiques of critical race
theory as an academic theory.
When you go to this is like Jews being excluded
from swimming pools and the precursors to
concentration camps, you just lose it.
And I would I would actually respect one of
these right wingers in their opposition to
critical race theory, much more if they just
levied a sober and sensible critique.
That's not what we're seeing from people like
Michael Savage.